[Music]
okay so good afternoon everybody my
name's Matt goodwitch and I'm a product
manager on the Android Enterprise team
it's not always I get the opportunity to
stand up on stage after sort of I video
like that which hopefully got you a bit
energized so thanks to our marketing
team for putting that together and what
I wanted to do was really spend the next
45 minutes giving you an overview of
what's new on Android Enterprise and and
what's coming up I think over the last
three or four years we've made huge
strides in and androids
readiness for enterprise I think if you
added androids
you know four years ago you probably
would have thought there was a maybe one
or two things missing but we've been
working really really hard the teams
work very hard to I think we can really
now say categorically that Android is
ready for business
but before we get started I just want to
do a quick show of hands how many of you
feel like you've got a reasonable
understanding of what Android Enterprise
is at this point okay so maybe a little
under half so what we'll do is we'll
spend a little bit of time to set a bit
at the context get those of you that
haven't experienced Android Enterprise
so far up to speed with what you know
the basics are and then we'll talk a bit
more about what's what's new and and
next and so to start with I really want
to begin with the opportunity that
Android poses for enterprises
not only is Android the operating system
that runs on on your smartphone in your
pocket or the tablet that you might
carry around in your bag it also runs on
point-of-sale systems virtual reality
headsets large screen digital displays
and even IOT
right so suddenly we've got a single
platform that covers a wide range of use
cases and across all of that we have the
same management and security
capabilities so you can then manage it
all of those different devices from the
same pane of glass through your EMM your
so your enterprise mobility manager or
your unified endpoint management system
so really huge opportunity there an
Android is a already a really prevalent
operating system within the enterprise
so across the over 2 billion Android
devices that they're active now globally
there's about 300 million devices that
are going to ship to enterprises this
year according to IDC and what you see
in these numbers is a sort of split
between individually liable devices so
these might be purchased personally and
then used at work so BYOD also so choose
your own devices where employers might
provide devices as part of you the
employer benefits and Android has your
80% of that market so quite close to the
consumer market share of well into the
18th percent so huge need really for
enterprises to think about when they're
offering BYO programs like making sure
Android is supported in corporate liable
68 percent event of smart device and
shipped into the enterprise are running
Android right so that's what's really
interesting and if as an enterprise you
haven't already approved Android for use
or you're you're not even considering
Android then you know you're really in
the minority now and you think about the
opportunities that you might be missing
out on for that from that breadth of
devices so we're going to talk about
today is is your Android in in four
different categories so first of all
we're going to talk a bit more about new
devices to fit your business and all
those different use cases
we can talk about you know how are you
management capabilities there's a really
comprehensive and innovative in the
mobile management space we're gonna
touch a little bit on security but my
colleague Dave Clyde Amaro is actually
speaking later who will dive into that
in a much much more detail and I'll
touch a little bit on some of the other
technologies that we're bringing into
Android which is enterprises you can you
can benefit from so let's first talk
about the the devices and I already
touched on just diversity of use cases
but here you can see that more
explicitly so all the way from the
traditional use cases of smartphones and
tablets through dedicated devices that
you know a logistics worker might use
when delivering a package to ensure you
know real-time delivery tracking through
to shared devices when you've got a
shelf of devices that a worker might
take out at the beginning of their shift
and then put back at the end of their
shift and making sure that we can deal
with the different login scenarios
deleting data from the devices when a
user logs out to make sure you've got
that sort of ephemerality of user data
kiosk devices embedded points of sale
digital displays of all kind of more of
the the dedicated of fixed cases virtual
reality is something that's new it's a
bit of a buzzword at the moment there's
lots of you know lots of talk about it
but enterprises are really interesting
use case for that we're seeing companies
go in and and have more immersive
training courses particularly for field
workers where they've actually got to
experience in some of the situations
they might find themselves in virtual
reality can be a really interesting
opportunity within the enterprise and
similarly augmented reality when you're
actually in a serve a field worker
scenario and you need help
being able to overlay that against your
field of view rather than having to look
up in a text document on a tablet for
example
and then finally IOT is an emerging area
there's obviously lots of presentations
here this week about IOT and how Google
cloud is going into the area and Android
with the recent launch GA launch of
Android things is also getting present
in there too one of the challenges we've
heard about the broad range of devices
though is that well how do I choose the
devices that I want in my enterprise
right there were over 400 different
manufacturers developing devices with
running Android and so navigating that
ecosystem is really really difficult so
what we did earlier this year is we
launched a program called Android
enterprise recommended what this does is
it creates a new czar a higher level of
requirements to around things like
security device capabilities and the
user accessory of the user experience
across devices to make sure that it's
easier for IT decision-makers to decide
which devices to purchase and then be
confident those devices have the
longevity and the simplicity required of
an enterprise environment so a lot of
that focuses on selection but
particularly a point which has been
painful in the Android ecosystem is
around updates and so what we do with
Android our enterprise recommended is
that those devices are required to have
90 day security patch updates for three
years after the release of that device
and they also have to have at least one
dessert release update as well so that
starting to push the Android ecosystem
into a more updated mode we've already
got now over 40 devices from 9 different
manufacturers and this is just gives you
some examples of some of the devices
that already ranged
now these you'll see that these are all
kind of high-end knowledge worker
devices
what we're doing now is we're working
with the OEMs to also come down the
range of price points to have a wide
range of mid tier and a lower tier
devices as well what we're starting to
hear from customers who are aware of the
android enterprise recommended program
sorry I'll try and get out of the way so
you can see is that the list of devices
that we've approved through AER is
actually helping customers now select
not only that the kinds of devices that
they want to purchase themselves as
corporate liable devices but also that
the set of devices that they're willing
to support as part of a bring your own
device program right so this was a
survey that we sent out to our customers
just recently and you really starting to
show a high degree of traction there how
are we evolving Android enterprise
recommend it
well we're bringing in new device types
so we've got a rugged a device program
coming in soon so slightly different set
of requirements there things like drop
test requirements coming in we're also
looking at applying the the principles
of Android enterprise recommended to
different partner types to the EA EA
sorry mm and um type vendors systems
integrators as well and there were also
developing programs for carriers and
developers too so we can give a degree
of confidence to our customers that
these products and services have reached
a surveyor higher bar so my colleague
Ken shut is actually going to be talking
in the next slot after this over the
weigh-in in Moscone West in much much
more detail about all these programs so
if you want to hit hear more do catch
his his session later on so this changed
gears now and talk about the the
comprehensiveness of our of androids
management framework and the way I want
to start here is with the range of
modes of operation that we have for
Android devices so starting on the left
hand side there for bring your own
device we have this concept called a
work profile what a work profile does is
it's a separate user really in the
Android operating system
but it's the apps and the data are shown
to users at the same time in the
launcher and they're and they're badged
with the little briefcase icon there so
users can see which whether they're
using the work app or the personal app
and you can navigate between these apps
just as you would any other two apps you
personally but the benefits are that you
can set policies around how enterprise
data can be shared you can switch off
things like copy/paste or sharing
between apps through the you know the
share sheet on apps they also benefit
for the user right the user can be
confident that their personal usage of
their own device isn't being monitored
by their IT department and should they
leave the company the only thing that
the IT department can delete is the
corporate data the work apps and data
leaving all of their personal apps and
data entirely untouched right so but
benefit actually for both sides it's
also now possible to be able to switch
off the work profile like on an evening
or a weekend or when you on vacation
which just enhances that their
capability to keep keep work separate
and out of your of your personal life
then moving on to the company own side
of things we can also have your fully
managed device which has a few more
capabilities around things like factory
reset protection and being able to
control what Wi-Fi hotspots a device can
attach to things our VPN as well but
also you can add a work profile to that
so you've still got the benefits of the
data separation but if you're a company
that wants to allow your users to use
the corporate devices personally and
have you employees only carry around one
device which is very convenient for them
then you can you can
we do that in a in a managed way of
course you can have your just a solely
fully managed device which is corporate
only and then we've also got a mode
similar to the fully managed device
which is what we call dedicated so this
is where and you can lock a single or a
very small number of apps to device
which use access to things like settings
or recents or notifications even and so
if you've got a a device for example for
logistics worker right who wants to
focus solely on delivering packages and
navigating to their next drop-off points
then you can do that without any risk of
the user accidentally or intentionally
changing settings and causing their
device to no longer work so
comprehensive set of different modes
depending on a particularly use case
that you're trying to roll out what a
highlight here just be the length of
time and effort that we've been we've
really spent on on building out the
feature set within android enterprise we
started off in lollipop with the the
initial iteration of the work profile
and the fully managed device and have
continued to evolve that over time
through to Android Audio which was
obviously released last fall and then
Android P that we've come in got coming
out fairly shortly I'll talk a little
bit more about that in a minute
the investment that we've been making
over the four years has really sort of
shown through in terms of the adoption
that we've seen from endless enterprises
globally actually this is not just
focused on North America we've also seen
extensive deployments in amia and J pack
and over the last two years we've
consistently seen 10x growth in that so
if you're considering now rolling out
Android Enterprise you can be confident
that we're here to stay because this is
really sort of a high-growth strategic
project from Google
so let's talk a bit more about how how
do we build features in what are the
principles by which we are evolving
Android enterprise first of all we
believe that any modern operating system
should enable a user to just carry
around a single device for work and for
personal of course if the IT policies
allow that but if we if there are cases
where that isn't possible
we still haven't quite got our work
profile right so we will continue to
evolve until we can make sure that every
user who is today carrying around two
devices can actually just carry around
one I already touched a little bit on
the one platform concept but it's really
really crucial that we allow a single
management capability across all of
those different use cases and we'll
continue to strive to make sure that
happens and then the other thing is
ensuring that app developers don't have
to build the same app multiple times for
different container technologies so the
work profile is built into the Android
operating system and will run any app
right there is no need for any
additional SDK or any kind of app
wrapping that's historically been
required so let's talk a little bit
about number of those things and one of
the challenges that we've really had for
a long time now since we launched
Android enterprises well what's what
isn't it's just Samsung Knox and like
what's the difference between Samsung
Knox and Android enterprise and to date
it's really been a choice for buyers of
Samsung devices we'll do you enroll as
him Knox what do you roll it in Android
enterprise well as of Android Oreo and
Knox 3.0 those two things are now coming
together and now Samsung Knox the
additional api's and capabilities that
Knox brings is built on top of the basic
Android enterprise concepts of fully
managed and work profile so when you
deploy Knox you actually already
deploying Android enter
with the extra bit on top right so you
no longer have to make a choice about
what you're deploying you could even
start with Android enterprise and then
upgrade to Knox at a later date so
really exciting it's of convergence
story there and we continue to work
closely with Samsung to evolve that that
relationship further you can see more
information from Samsung about the
unification just there
another thing about one platform and if
you saw the previous session where Mike
Burr was hosting a number of partners
customers just before this who we've
we've got an increasing number of
companies working on dedicated devices
so here are three customer examples of
cases where they've they're deploying in
some cases quite interesting hardware
and then locking apps to that screen to
to focus user attention on on the tasks
that that equipment is designed for so
on the left hand side here Marks and
Spencers which is a very large retailer
in the UK deploying dedicated devices to
their store the shop floor assistants to
really give them real-time information
to help customers with with their
shopping
Pitney Bowes was actually on stage I saw
over the way there just earlier who have
got famous brand here in the u.s. they
have a product which is a postage meter
so you can print you know postage labels
and things and and pay for the postage
with the device but now it's a connected
product actually running Android and
that's enabled a wide range of
developers and apps to come onto that
platform to actually extend the
capabilities of a product that they
already have within the office and then
Crona post is a European logistics
company who have just rolled out Android
devices as well
and you see like you know by the numbers
substantial volumes are of devices for
for these kinds of sectors so you
already mentioned Android PE and there's
certainly no let-up on an android in
terms of the investment that we're
putting in and a couple of focus areas I
want to talk about with we're we're
focusing down on on more dedicated
devices and particularly around things
that shift workers and shared devices so
imagine you've got a you're a factory or
a warehouse where you've got a shift
workers they sign out a a device at the
beginning of their shift they can log in
and get the apps and services that they
need as that particular individual right
they don't need to worry about getting
the right device for the apps the app
the device will adapt to them if they
have different needs right and we
provide that now natively in the
platform we were also introducing a new
as last are the updated user experience
to the work profile to really help users
better understand this concept of
separation between the work and personal
apps we felt that the the ability to mix
and match the apps across your launcher
your in any which way is sometimes a
little counterintuitive to users who who
don't understand correctly the how the
data separation works so we were finding
that the other exciting thing about
Android pee
is that for the first time in androids
history not only if we launched the beta
program for Google's own hardware of
course the pixel we've also launched the
beta program for seven other OEMs and
the reason why that's been possible this
time is because of investments we made
in Oreo where we introduced a project
called project treble you might have
heard of that it's be it was talked
about a lot in the press when we
launched at i/o last year the wall that
introduced is a hardware abstraction
layer between all of the device drivers
and the kernel
versus the rest of the OS or the system
libraries the UI etc and what's that's
that's meant is it's much simpler for
the the OEMs the device manufacturers to
update the operating system on top of
that existing board Support Package for
the lower-level code and so you now is a
really really good opportunity to get
devices into your labs to start testing
new they're really the latest
functionality because it's it's coming
down the pike actually quite a lot
quicker than previous releases my
colleague James is actually going to be
talking in a lot more detail with some
demos as well on the the new features in
Android P so if you're interested in
that do check that out at 3:15 over in
the the Metreon let's sort of little bit
on on deployment so management's all
very well and good but unless you can
simply deploy those devices into an
enterprise you're still going to have
some challenges Android has actually got
a choice of different ways that you can
bootstrap enrolment and this is
particularly focused on the fully
managed kind of devices you can use QR
codes or NFC for NFC compatible devices
you can have a text so token that's
issued by your EMM but the most recent
edition which we introduced in Android
Audio is zero touch so let's just talk a
little bit about the details of zero
touch what this does is it gives you a
completely seamless experience when
unboxing a device right so you don't
have to send devices round down a you
know sort of a white glove service or
have them pre-enrolled by an IT
administrator as soon as the user
unboxes that device powers it on and
connects it to a network and if it's a
smart phone you might have a sim in
there which will just get a network
anyway then it will automatically read
its configuration in its Ruhlman details
from a server and then immediately
download that managing app which ever
app it is
for whichever of your your favorite emm
is and then it will apply the policy
immediately so you're up and running
really in in very little time with very
little opportunity for the user to make
mistakes as well the other cool thing
about this is if you were to try and set
up the device without connecting to a
network of course it can't talk to the
server to get its policy but as soon as
that device does connect to a network it
goes our half I should have been
enrolled in full management and force
the user to factory reset it and then go
into an enrollment cycle so it's also a
little bit of a kind of theft protection
or protection against misuse as well so
just a little bit more about how that
works well we need to get cooperation
from a number of different stakeholders
now remember here we're not just doing
this for one device manufacturer we're
doing it for a whole ecosystem and that
has quite a few challenges so first of
all we need manufacturers to certify
their solutions with us and also ensure
that they are putting unique serial
numbers onto devices that's actually not
always happened in the past so there's
some process assurance that needs to
happen we work with carriers and
resellers as sort of the trusted channel
partner to ensure that when devices are
sold they were signed to the correct
customer within Google's back-end
systems to enforce that enrollment
because we what we want to avoid is any
sort of device hijacking after a device
is sold right so we ensure that there
and then from a customer and perspective
they can use their EMM then to apply the
correct policy to that device so that
when it boots into an enrolled state
it's straight in with the with the right
settings so we've already been working
extensively with partners in all of
those areas and so this gives you a
sense of all of those different partners
that support Xero touched
and we've got more coming soon on the
manufacturers there are a lot of the
more dedicated type devices from
companies like Panasonic Honeywell and
zebra and there's more some EMS and
carriers in the pipe as well which
unfortunately I can't disclose today but
you'll see they not just it's a region
specific but you know organizations from
around the world who are participating
in this program so we're we're super
excited with the velocity that we've got
there I want to switch gears now talk
about app management and what we do with
with that management in Android is
actually we leverage Google Play and
then add-on management layer on top to
make sure that IT departments have full
control of what's going on now the
question are you all saying as well why
would I want to use Google Play which is
like full of games and all that sort of
stuff for managing enterprise apps well
the great thing about Google Play is
it's it's a huge platform it's secure
it sort of authenticates the install of
those apps and it makes sure that apps
are appropriately signed it has global
server footprint so we can always
deliver the best experience to your
users in terms of download performance
wherever they are in the world
it applies patch updates so you don't
have to download it the same apk over
and over again and we also do our apps
get or apk scanning which is of course
part of our security model but if you're
thinking about private apps or
internally developed apps right well why
would you want your apk scans well the
interesting thing about private apps is
that very often you're using third-party
SDKs you might be employing an agency to
build it for you and you've got no idea
what coding standards they hot but they
uphold so apk scanning and not only
scans for you know bad things happening
around malware but also against sort of
vulnerable third-party SDKs so avoid
things like heartbleed in open SSL for
example
it also comes with comprehensive
publishing tools which you can use for
your privates crash and performer
supporting your other reporting tools in
terms of installs it manages updates for
you and then recently we just announced
at Google i/o this concept of an Android
app bundle where for different devices
you might download different assets so
let's say you've got different image
densities different resolutions of
images assets within your apk well what
Android app bundle does is it
selectively installs just the assets
that are required for the device that's
being installed rather than everything
and that saves you bandwidth it saves
you battery life and it saves you
storage on the device so lots of new
reasons why Google Play is a great
platform to build on top of and then
bring the management on top of that you
can then create an enterprise store
using of course a familiar user
experience for your users you can
silently push install apps so for
example when a device is enrolled you
can push apps automatically as soon as
that device boots up so that a user is
ready to work immediately
you can also push configurations to
those to those apps so for example a VPN
app can be quite complicated to to set
up there's lots of different quite
technical parameters there but you can
make sure that a user doesn't have to
worry about that by sending the
configuration bundle down to the the app
at the same time as the install
I already commented on the ability to
distribute private apps and we make sure
that those are logically separate from
any public apps on Play so you can be
confident that they are only
distributable to your employees but you
can also arrange them within your
enterprise app store side by side with
public apps so an employee doesn't
really have to worry about whether this
is a private apple or public app they
just install the apps that are
lies to them and then finally the new
thing that we've introduced very
recently is a data processing agreement
as part of our contractual terms for
managed Google Play what that means is
is that we've now got contract we've got
a contract in place to give you
confidence that we will only use any
data that we collect for providing the
manage play service and not for anything
else recently we've made some
improvements to manage play of course
it's now possible to programmatically
publish private apps rather than having
to go into a separate console which is
the Play publishing console so there's a
there's a short link there if you want
to look at that if you want to build
that into your own publishing tools for
example or your your development
workflows internally there's a new API
now to determine how and when at updates
happen so whether you allow them only
over Wi-Fi or you'll also permit them
over cellular or not at all and you can
also do per device at authorization so
historically that was always done on a
user basis but if the same user has a
BYO smartphone and a corporate owned
tablet you might actually want to offer
them different sets of apps for that
same user for different security
environments and if that's now possible
we're also introducing some additional
UI features so these are this is of an
embeddable widget that your EMM s will
be able to embed and you'll be pleased
to know if you're using Google Mobile
Management as part of G Suites this is
going to these features are going to
come in as soon as they launch later on
this quarter so there'll be a visual
user interface for publishing privates
so as part of the same EMM experience
you no longer have to chop and change
between consoles we're introducing the
concept of web app publishing so you'll
be able to push like a a web app to the
users launcher
so that they can go straight to the
internet or other web tools that you
might have and they were also building a
sort of a drag-and-drop store builder so
when you're curating an enterprise app
store you can actually create new
clusters of apps you can place the apps
where you want in a very visual way
drag-and-drop to make it very very quick
to curate that enterprise app store and
get that out to your users finally I
want to talk about the Android
management API which is a new API that
we've built that really enables new
bespoke solutions within an enterprise
or indeed developers who want to build
device management into a wider solution
so maybe you're building I don't know a
meeting room management product right
but you want to manage those sort of
like tablets within the meeting them as
part of the same product and actually
Android management API is new the best
way now to start doing it it's a cloud
epi
so rather than having to build a sort of
an agent app on the device you can just
send policies over that API and so it's
much much simpler to have a single
consistent API rather than having to
build a agent go talk to manage play
separately who send push notifications
separately as well very very powerful
we're we're updating that every six
weeks we have a comprehensive set of
functionality not quite everything that
Android OS offers directly yet but we're
getting there and it's built by the same
team that builds the OS right so we make
sure that we're implementing the
features exactly the way as they were
they were designed and it's policy based
so you don't need to worry about all of
the different new sequence of
interactions you can set a policy and
then just forget about it so I'm
actually going to be talking much more
detail about that if you're interested
they'll be here tomorrow afternoon at
4:35
okay let's quickly touch on security and
Android will he takes a defense-in-depth
approach to security so let's start on
the bottom on the hardware side we
support dedicated security hardware
whether that's a trusted execution
environment as part of the new standard
chipset which is usually part a
dedicated part of the the processor on
board or indeed discreet secure element
hardware which is adds extra tamper
resistance to the products and some of
the tasks so that can achieve our first
of all managing authentication through
things like key lock managing your
encryption keys and another other very
sensitive tasks the OS itself is
hardened against potential attack right
so we employ a number of different
technologies to ensure that things like
a address randomization to make sure
that you know if an if a hacker achieves
a particular exploits it's very much
more difficult to replicate that from
one device to the next we of course have
the management api's which can enforce
your management security policies over
the top and then Google Play protects
which is a always on call it a antivirus
or anti-malware products which always is
is adapting to identify and remove the
latest malware from devices so really
keeping some end-to-end protection I'm
not going to go into any more detail on
security at this point Dave
Clyde Amato who's the VP of Android
Security's can be presenting there
shortly this afternoon so if you're
interested in that do check that out
finally on a close with just the level
of innovation that you benefit from when
you invest in in and
so this is not necessary specific
enterprise features but many many
different things going on I just want to
call out a few so I've already touched
on augmented reality but the if you want
to build some of these cutting-edge
experiences whether that's for training
or for field services a our core is a
really good place to start
a our core is a library which does some
of the heavy lifting for you so you can
focus on really the value add elements
of the your app so things like motion
tracking detecting services which you
can then place objects on virtually or
light estimation so you can really make
sure that your objects are rendered
appropriately for the environment that
you're looking at all of that is taken
care for you so you don't have to worry
about you know the detailed challenges
with with some of the sensors machine
learning obviously a huge topic here at
next this week but Android supports you
a whole stack of different capabilities
so at the bottom of the stack here
you've got the neural networks API so
that's a native API on Android but
really helps you figure out which is the
most optimal hardware to use for your
influence only for your learning so if
all you've got is a CPU then it will
default to that all the way up to some
of the latest devices have TP use are
built into them and of course neural
networks API will make sure that those
fastest Hardware is used tend to flow
light then abstract that a bit further
and you can build neural nets very
quickly with just a few lines of code
all the way up to ml kitc which enables
you to do your learning in the cloud
compress that neural network model and
then deploy it to devices for influence
very very quickly devices like here the
the Huawei p20 have already got that TPU
chip built in and here you can see a
performance improvement of 10x so a
tenth of the time taken to do
you a neural network in influence using
this product so a really huge advance
advancements taking place across the the
Android ecosystem there and then another
thing you know I already mentioned IOT
but Android things went to you earlier
this year and a huge opportunity for
enterprises to leverage the same
technologies that we've built here
whether that's from the security side so
making sure you thing has got got things
like hardware route of trust and all the
encryption key support all the way up to
you know the connectivity options and
the management support that you need so
just then to conclude I really encourage
you when you're thinking about you
mobile devices and endpoints in general
think beyond the knowledge worker
situation or a scenario of like devices
in people's pockets and think about what
are the opportunities you have to
improve at your employee workflows or
even end customer experiences whether
that's in a retail store your or
elsewhere take a look at the Android
enterprise recommended program if you
are in the process or soon to be looking
at what devices to purchase Android
enterprise recommended can give you a
really good sense of of one of the
devices that meet some of those critical
Enterprise requirements and also one of
those could you leverage that for
curating the set of devices that you
support within a BYOD and then finally
when you're purchasing your devices make
sure that you're doing that through a
zero touch enabled reseller because as
you're purchasing them then that we sell
it will be able to remark close in the
zero touch system to are owned by you
and then you can benefit from that
really frictionless approach to
enrolling devices when they're deployed
to users
and then finally take a look at Android
pee there's now your eight different
device manufacturers that support that
so really great opportunity now to get
that into your test labs and and see
what the opportunities are that that
that brings so with that just to close
here's a quick summary of the other
sessions going on about Android
enterprise this week feel free to take a
photo the only one I haven't mentioned
is the last one using mobile as a
catalyst for digital transformation my
colleague Sean I'm sorry I'll get out of
the way then you can take a photo my
colleague Sean is going to be talking
through so a bit more high-level around
like how can you apply Android and its
technologies to really transform
businesses thank you very much
[Music]